but yeah I find that uh that it's
interesting that we're finding like guys
like you Jordan Peterson
um and you guys work together
we recall these Jordan was just down the
hallway for me uh we continue uh to keep
in communication uh because he doesn't
teach anymore now does he no I mean he
had a very he had a very fraught
relationship with the university oh he
did yeah uh and uh uh yeah
um and I think there was fault on both
sides in that issue
um I mean but I want to be very clear I
have a really good relationship uh with
the University of Toronto they've
treated me uh well the psychology
department at least has treated me
extremely extremely well yeah right but
Jordan and I were we're colleagues we
were very friendly colleagues uh we
shared students uh we we were we would
frequently find ourselves at the same
conference same conference talking about
stuff that's fun was it fun to discuss
things with him and be able to
communicate yeah yeah yeah
um and
I want to say this very carefully
because whatever you say about Jordan
Peterson it'll bite you in the ass no
matter what you say uh is Jordan
Jordan's a very divisive person but um
Jordan
and is reciprocated Jordan respects me
when Jordan respects you
he interacts with you differently that
if he doesn't respect you or he doesn't
know if he should respect you then he
interacts that this is at least to my
mind it could be a safety mechanism too
it could be a safety mechanism it could
also be that uh that's the kind of
teacher he was very care there were
three life-changing professors at the
University of Toronto uh one I won't
mention his name
um and the other two are myself and
Jordan Peterson and
um and so we often shared students
like I said I've always had I've always
had and I've appreciated very good
relationships with Jordan I don't agree
with Jordan on certain things especially
political things
um
but you see like when when some of the
stuff dropped initially I would send I'd
send him an email and I'd say here's my
arguments against your position
um but I think they should treat you
with respect you're making a point you
should be treated with like the way he
shouldn't have just been sneered at or
yelled at they should have like they
should have they should he deserved to
be given a good
hearing a good counter argument yeah I
think what you get once you get to a
certain level kind of a popularity and
once you're in the social media sphere
in some sense you don't it becomes more
of like a a Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome
out there and not as much of uh probably
the grounds you guys are used to where
people communicate yeah and so the thing
is like when I would write them that
email uh he would say thank you like he
was appreciative or like you know I'll
be on his uh you know Channel with him
and he'll he'll you know he'll criticize
post-modernism and I'll say well I think
there's value to post-modernism and
here's the value and here's like you
know Foucault was saying this and yeah
you know and there that I was saying uh
and you know and he'll be responsive and
respect respectful yeah right and so but
but
the the the thing about that is is
like it's it
I want to maintain a good relationship
with like when he somehow he found out I
had diabetes and he sent me a like a
supportive email and I appreciate that
like I I I believe and this will get me
in hot water with some people but I
believe that Jordan is fundamentally a
good person and I think he has very good
intent and I think he's terrifically
talented
um but
um well the things that make you
adaptive make you prone to
self-deception and there's things that
he also uh we fundamentally don't agree
on yeah but but right
I think if people if we could get out of
the polarization around him and to be
fair I think he contributes to it I
don't he's I think by his own admission
he's not very good on Twitter yeah right
right yeah right no I think he would
admit that I better think of what we
talked about when I was with when I
chatted with him if we could if we could
get out of polarizing and if he could
get out of being caught up in that
like what's really impressive is like
like when I've talked to him or John and
Jonathan and pajo and I talked to him
he'll get a lot of comments like do more
of those Jordan do more of those yeah
right because for me I feel like that's
the Jordan that I really respect and I
have affection for coming to the fore
and then there's this other aspect of
him that I I can't
I I can't connect to him yeah maybe he
likes to get into the fracus of it you
know well see that's a philosophical
difference between us I think trying to
solve
the meaning crisis at the adversarial
level of propositional just ideas and
ideologies and that kind I don't think
it can be solved there we've been
talking about a much different level in
much different ways in which the meaning
crisis has to be solved I think I I'm I
I and I don't this isn't a this isn't a
scapegoat I did this costs me so this is
this doesn't come for free this isn't a
couple I'm meta political I think that
trying to get engaged with this problem
in a political framing is fundamentally
a modal confusion it is to make that
kind of profound mistake I think the
left at its best reminds us that we're
finite animals subject to fate and we
have to show compassion to each other
and the right at its best reminds us
that we're also called to Transcendence
and the cultivation of virtue and when
they worked where they were correcting
each other and helping each other emerge
and we're committed to democracy then we
have something wonderful when they break
that up into winner take all the other
side is evil and I have to destroy them
then that society that democracy is
doomed and over and I think that's where
our political situation is so I refuse
like Socrates I refuse and Plato I
refuse to participate in the political
yeah domain because for me I do not and
see Jordan wants to go in there guns
blazing and that's a fundamental
difference between us and so we've come
to understand that we won't talk about
those things right those are just ways
you guys are and I'm glad we probably
need people to be both ways I think I
think some of the online stuff gets like
um
it gets uh addictive probably you know
it is yeah I think once you get into
that world there's people that their
whole lives are that world you know and
he loves to argue points so I think if
you want to argue stuff yeah yeah you
can do it all day there yeah but it's
argument it's argument for uh Plato made
a distinction between Philo Sophia the
love of wisdom and Philo Nikia the love
of Victory and when it's the love of
Victory then you've lost the socratic
Spirit right right like I will disagree
with people Bishop Maximus and I we
disagree he's he is a committed and I
think profound and virtuous Christian
I'm not we know this and yet and but so
we disagree and profound and yet he's
one of my dearest friends and we draw
each other out and we contribute to each
other right you can disagree you can
argue you can challenge but you don't
have to pursue demonization destruction
you don't have to pursue confirmation
porn you don't have to pursue narrative
porn you know what the narrative is of
narrative is I this is a real but I can
tell a story about that so I must mean I
know what's going on right and so we get
simplistic narratives we get
confirmation porn we get this we get
this sort of self this self-righteous
adversarial I'm gonna destroy the other
animal and see it shows how good and
it's ultimately narcissistic I I don't
want to participate in any of that crap
right right and and so you can see I'm
getting very animated that's okay it's
interesting I feel I feel I feel very
strongly that so sorry I I want to make
it clear that I'm not arguing against
Jordan in his absence he I would welcome
if he was here and could defend his
position yeah yeah I don't think that we
are I think I have a decent enough
relationship with and I'm sure you have
a great relationship with so it's like I
would understand if he wouldn't be upset
I don't think so I think he I think he
understands that we're like yeah he he
he's invited me to do things like to uh
he's putting together a new course
Peterson Academy and I've had it I've
I've already done one course form on
intelligence rationality wisdom and
spirituality uh but when he when he came
to when he made the offer to me he said
well I said Jordan I'm not a
conservative I'm not a Christian and I
have ideas other than yours he said
first of all you can criticize me if you
want you have complete academic freedom
and you don't have to be a Christian and
you don't have to tow the conservative
line I just want you to come in and give
the best possible course you could give
and I said okay under those conditions
I'll do it because why wouldn't I that's
a completely virtuous context yeah and I
hate guilt by association well you're
associating with them you you really
that's become a huge problem in politics
overall in society you you you can't do
that you're right you you like like it's
so funny like people don't even realize
like the guilt by association and then
the little spouse sort of Foucault and
post-modernism who are deeply influenced
profoundly influenced by Heidegger who
was literally Nazi right it's like what
what where does your guilt by how does
your guilt by association metric work
right it doesn't work consistently it
doesn't work coherently
um and you know I think that
it's important that we give people a
chance
to enter into genuine theologos with us
that we don't you know
part of understanding forgiveness which
is an important part of Agape that's
Jesus of Nazareth if forgiveness isn't
like Mercy I I let you off the hook
forgiveness is I'm giving you the chance
to enter into a relationship with me and
even given myself to enter in a chance
into relationship with you before it has
been earned
because something has happened that I
can't earn it until like I'm in a
catch-22 unless you give me the chance
to enter the relationship I can't do the
things that will allow me to re-earn
your trust right and so you need to give
me that right you need to forgive I'm
playing with the word a little bit right
you need to forgive and and make the so
that we're not bound in reciprocal
nearing so there's a chance for
reciprocal opening